Am Start wieder
Ich hab Overwatch wieder installiert
Stellt euch das vor
Nachdem ich ja Rage quitted hab
Moin Rofsky01
Nein einfach nur 1
Moin Akimopro
Ja mal gucken wie es heut läuft
Letzter Tag der Season
Hoffentlich letzter Tag von Mercy Meta
Wobei sich das ja nicht
Da auch kein Ende abzeichnet
Irgendwie ne
Kann alles sein, dass Overwatch irgendwie nicht richtig gecaptured wird
Sieht man jetzt was?
Ja wunderbar perfekt
Easy
Easy clap
Welche Elo ist dein Main?
Ich hab keine Placements gemacht
Auf meine Main
Ich hab meine Main seit Season 3 nicht mehr gespielt
Deswegen auch ein neuer Account
Also quasi für die aktuelle Season
Ist das hier mein Main
Und ich bin jetzt Decade runter auf
Aber nicht viel Decade
Wann haben wir gespielt das letzte Mal vor 1,5 Wochen oder so?
Weiß ich gar nicht
Muss ich mal in die Wots gucken
Wann haben wir das letzte Mal Overwatch gespielt?
Ähm
Sind wir noch gar nicht Decade?
Oder?
Vielleicht einen Tag Decade oder so
Gucken
Ich muss jetzt noch warten bis der Eaxe wieder da ist
Dann gehts los
Ich werd aber nur so lange spielen
Bis der Overwatch Rank Tilt wieder zu groß wird
Dann mach ich heut aus
Dann kreiselcryten wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen
Discord Overlay, das ist Absicht
Das ist Absicht
Ich bin auch nicht allein hier
Der Eaxe ist normalerweise
Er ist da, aber er ist gerade auf K
Ich find das neue Discord Overlay
Ehrlich gesagt ziemlich stylisch gemacht
Besser als das alte
Wir müssen Lootboxen aufmachen
Da hab ich das letzte Mal im Stream schon gesagt
Mach ich
Dann hab ich Rage quittet
Da war nix mehr mit Lootboxen öffnen
Lootboxen
Was ist das hier eigentlich?
Ach Tim, da konnte man Hearthstone Karten kaufen
Also richtig sinnloses
Wo ich mich frage, was macht man damit so?
Oh
Jetzt kann ich Hotsboxen kaufen
Und Heroes of the Storm Packs
Das muss ich unbedingt
Über Overwatch machen
Das ist ein Feature, da hab ich schon
Seit Release von geträumt ehrlich gesagt
Ich hab auch schon
Heimlich Briefe an Jeff geschrieben
Wann ich endlich Heroes of the Storm
Und Hearthstone Packs kaufen kann
Das wird das Overwatch Hauptmenü
Erzählst du eigentlich davon, dass die Season so kurz gemacht wurde?
Wusste ich bis jetzt gar nicht
Ich weiß nur, dass heute
Letzter Tag der Season ist
Season Overwatch
Mal gucken, auf einmal geht die neue los
Schauen wir mal
Season Overwatch
Da bin ich schonmal gespannt
Ich mein, es hat sich am Prinzip seit Season 2
geändert
Hab ja Blizzard das so gesagt
Da wird das so sein
Irgendwann
Jeff hat uns ja quasi neuneinhalb Stunden
So in die Seele gestartet
Im Weihnachtstream
Hat das eigentlich jemand geschaut?
Hat jemand
In den Weihnachtsteam geschaut?
So, gucken wir mal in die Lootbox rein
Was haben wir denn?
Epic Reinhardt
Den brauchen wir
Ich hab schon Stream an
Endlich mal ein ordentlicher Reinhardt Stream
Äh, skin
Ich will gar kein Reinhardt spielen
Wahrscheinlich wirds wie der Reinhardt
Orissa Mercy Stream oder sowas
Weil ich wieder was spielen muss
Was ich nicht spielen will
Ich mach grad noch mal Lootbox da auf
Hab ich letztens schon gesagt, dann nicht gemacht
Ein Hanzo Player Icon
Das wollt ich schon immer mal
Ich hab grad auch eine aufgemacht
Es wird nix angezeigt
Das sind einfach zwei leere Flächen
Das ist auch toll
Wenn du bei Hero Gallery
Auf alles markieren gedrückt
Könntest du jetzt quasi indirekt sehen, was du gekriegt hast
Aber wer macht das nach jeder Lootbox?
Was ist da für ein Bug?
Du musst vielleicht mal neu starten
Neustart hilft bei allem
Hab ich schon mal erzählt im Stream
Als mein Kühlschrank Geräusche gemacht hat
Hab ich Strom rausgezogen, wieder reingesteckt
Macht keine Geräusche mehr
Ich hilf Tribut
Ist die Lautstärke von Eaxe okay?
Ich hab nichts verstellt
Aber das heißt ja nichts
Das haben wir ja mittlerweile gelernt
Das ist die beste Lucio Voice Line
Nicht weil er Jackpot sagt
Sondern weil er sagt
Das kannst du dann so spammen
Hattest du Overwatch nicht installiert?
Sagt der Twitch Mason
Ja mich, ich hab's wieder installiert
Ist gar nicht nervig oder?
Ist das Spiel überhaupt laut genug?
Ich muss gerade mal meinen Stream reinhören
Aber ich glaub das geht
Wenn nicht kann ich das Game doch ein Ticken lauter machen
Wenn es nicht passen sollte
Sound
Also ich kann auch lauter machen wenn es zu leise ist
Dann sind wir gleich in Game
Kannst du den weiten?
Ja kannst du machen
Bist du auch einmal Decade
Oder waren wir schnell genug mit Spiel?
WTF
Warum hast du 3811
Und ich habe 3609
Wir haben nur zusammengespielt
Ah ja gut einmal Telekom Fail
Sauerei
Aber das ist halt eine persönliche Performance
Das Game will mir quasi mitteilen
Ich sacke und du nicht
Ich fühle mich offended
Wir sollten jetzt unbedingt ins Battlelog Forum posten
Und Jeff fragen was das soll
Ich fühle mich in meiner Game Experience gestört
So ich suche mal Game
So Leute wenn wir in Game sind
Schreibt mal bitte in Chat ob Lautstärke stimmt
In Game von mir, von Eax und sonst was
Weil ich habe es ein bisschen umgestellt
Allerdings nicht die Lautstärke
Sondern nur was er für eine Soundkarte verwendet
Ich habe jetzt
Die Musik im Hintergrund
Und den Eax
Auf der zweiten Soundkarte
Über die zweite Soundkarte ins OBS rein
Und Game Sound über die erste Soundkarte
Das hat den Vorteil wenn ich jetzt Shadowplay
Capture
Dann nimmt das Game Sound auf
Ohne meinen Gelaber
Ohne Eax Gelaber und ohne Musik
Was sich auch besser für YouTube eignet
Juncker
Moment was ist das für ein Game
Was haben wir hier gelandet
Komm wir machen Bastion Strat
Wir machen Bastion Strat
Nee nicht mit unranked Leuten
Das kannst du voll gerne
Komm lass mal
Easy win
Bastion Strat
Na gut dann mach Schwänzen
Das ist auch der Hammer
Ich habe es ja erst angesprochen gehabt
Unranked kurz vor Season 1
Das machen die jetzt alle nochmal ihre Placements
Oder was
Kurz vor Schluss
Sieht so aus ne
Eax könnte
Ein Ticken lauter sein
Das lässt sich
Einrichten
Oder auch nicht
Das ist ja witzig
Ich habe in meiner
Mixer Einstellung
Habe ich kein
Kein Discord mehr drin
Ich weiß nicht wo das hin ist
Aber ich kann nicht den Discord lauter machen
Ein bisschen
Sag mal bitte was
Hallo Testest
Jetzt müsste es ein Ticken lauter sein
Müsste ein Ticken lauter sein
Ich werde nicht meinen neuen Bildschirm haben
Nee
Ich bin langsam schon
Richtig ungeduldig, das glaubst du gar nicht
Was haben wir hier für eine
Wir haben keinen Heiler
Hatten wir nicht ein Lucio?
Ja
Also ich kann gerade nicht gucken
Wir haben nur noch ein Lucio
Sonst nichts
Das ist für ein Arsch
Das geht nicht
Was haben wir denn sonst
Wir haben nur eine Zarya als Tank
Was ist das
Okay
Ich spiele mal Ana
Ich habe keinen Bock auf Mercy
Ich kriege Anfälle wieder wenn ich Mercy spielen muss
Aber easy
Das sind bestimmt Noobs
Gut sind die Gegner nicht
Aber wir auch nicht
Das ist ja meistens so
Lucio lass dich doch mal hitten alter
Hat er keinen Bock drauf
Da wird gebrutzelt
Genau deshalb spiele ich keinen
Overwatch
Das ist halt wächerlich
Hallo
Ich habe mir vorgenommen heute wird sich nicht aufgeregt
Ich muss mich einspielen
Die Symmetra steht links alleine
Achtung hinter dir
Ist ziemlich schlau
Ich habe die Barrier zu spät
Schade
Das ist mega für einen Arsch
Was können wir denn hier machen
Es ist einfach total wir
Außer Mercy zu spielen
Das wird wieder der Tank
Mit Winston kann es knicken ohne Lucio
Mit Lucio solo hier
Wo sind die Symmetra
Die lebt noch
Ich habe einen anderen
Du hast auch jetzt noch ein Schild
Blizzard hat nicht alle Boxen überarbeitet
Mercy zeig dich
Piss dich
Was geht da hinter euch ab
Lucio du kannst jetzt healen
Das wäre ganz nice
Hast du Weiser
Ich kann nichts machen
Es ist überall jemand
Überall
Der schläft
Linke Seite
Alter Leute
Macht diesen verfickten Soldier tot
Hallo
Ich fühle mich absolut machtlos
Das ist komplett random
What the fuck
Der wird jetzt gebashed
Bist du runtergefallen
Letzten Tag der Season
Sind immer absolut qualitativ
Die hochwertigsten
Die Abstand
Ich finde hochwertig
Nein
Ich wurde gegrillt
Weil ich mal sleep gemisst habe
Super Jeff
Dankeschön für das Match
Heute werde ich nicht getillt
Heute werden ein paar Matches gespielt
Das ist die über krasse Experience
Der Soldier ist auch noch so schlecht
Jetzt werden wir geputzt
Ja
Ich meine es ist ja nicht so, dass wir ihn nicht killen
Könnte oder so
Auf Leute
Leute
Lauft
Lauft Leute
Ich muss DPS machen
Ich checke
Das ist absolut
Ich blicke nicht durch
Das ist mir
Das ist mir zu hoch gerade
Ich bin nicht in der Lage
Die
Die den IQ aufzubringen
Das ist auf 9000
Was man hier IQ braucht für das Game gerade
Wow, ich habe dauerhaft steht
Ich bin null
Moment, der Typ war kurz drinne
Der war kurz wieder ingame
Oder
Jetzt wird er raus
Ja ich hatte ja auch Overwatch den scene
So ist das halt
Wenn man ein Spiel eigentlich geil findet
Ja, das ist das
Oh knapp
Der hat bestimmt Shatterwave
Der guckt, der guckt, der guckt
Richtig
Ich muss mit ansäugen
Ich muss weg hier
Ich war voll in meinem Gesicht
Ich musste mich gerade entscheiden
Zwischen gelassert werden oder explodieren
Ich versuche mich mal zu verpissen
Alter mach den Soldier tot
Hilfe, helft mir und weckt die doch nicht auf
Alter
Der Soldier, der Soldier ist so low
Und wieder gebutzt worden
Oh wir sind wieder 6
Wir sind wieder 6 Leute
Easy win, easy win
Hey hast du nicht Overwatch installiert
Doch habe ich
Hab ich
Jetzt ist es aber wieder installiert
Du wolltest bloß die Dateien erneuern
Genau
Und erhofft, dass ich das Game von selbst fix
fix
So easy
Wir brauchen jetzt
Komm haben wir nicht einen der Mercy spielen kann
Haben wir nicht
Ausverrecken haben wir nicht
Hast du nicht Overwatch
Du bist jetzt, Joshi du bist schon der 10te
der fragt ob ich Overwatch nicht
installiert hat
Warum wir Lucio spielen ist glaube ich relativ
einfach, weil dieser
Welfi oder wer das genau war
halt nur Lucio spielt
Ich gehe mal in Team Boys
Was das abgeht
Haben die das Game schon mal gespielt
Sehst du doch
Also wirklich
Ich glaube er hat es wieder installiert
Ja habe ich
Ich wollte mir den letzten
Season Tag nicht entgehen lassen
mit seinen absolut high quality Matches
Ich bin runter gesprungen, ich bin dumm
Moment ist Orisa so dick
dass die hier nicht hoch kann? Kann das sein?
Ja Orisa und Reinwaffe
Das ist doppelt
Ich habe den perfekten Pick dafür
Und RIP
Ich kann da nicht viel machen gerade
Ich gehe da jetzt ran
Easy easy hold
Okay nein das funktioniert so nicht
Was spielen wir da jetzt?
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Müssen wir gucken
Ich könnte ein Winston spielen
Aber da wäre ich geschreddert von Bastion
Wir diving garantiert da nicht koordiniert drauf
Irgendwie
Ich spiele Zen
Easy damage
Die haben nichts was mich mit Zen koordinieren kann
Ey komm mal die haben Attack Symmetra
Please
Mein Aim ist der Wahnsinn mit Zen
Ich spam mit Symmetra auf
Der Bastion ist mega low
Der wird gerade gehackt glaube ich
Was war denn das?
Wir haben den Bastion ausgesitcht
Das ist schonmal nicht schlecht
Haben sie einen Flanker der mich abfucken könnte?
Naja nicht wirklich
Genji
Ah fuck wo kommt denn der her?
War das vorher der Bastion?
Ich glaube so
Oh er busy overextendet oder?
Der Gude
Er busy overextendet
Ich komme gleich da
Ich bin gleich da mit Ulti
Die Mercy ist rechts
Mein Zen Aim war auch schonmal
Genauer
Irgendwo hinter uns steht ein TP
Ich treffe nicht mehr mit Zen
Das ist übelst freundlich
Nein
Genji noch gefistet
Wir haben TP rechts
Wir können das sogar halten
Die sind so auch übelst schlecht
Trefft zwar auch nicht
Aber die Gegner sind wirklich schlecht
Ich bin doch nicht da
Haben wir nicht noch einen zweiten Heal?
Ach wir haben wieder ein Lucio
Wir haben keine Mercy mehr deswegen
Warum haben wir keine Mercy?
Wie sind wir drei Spawns unten?
Alles ist weg
Kann es sein, dass wir gerne
Overextenden des Todes machen?
Ich meine es gibt ja eigentlich keinen Grund
Jetzt da im Spawn zu stehen
Naja doch Ulti ist fun
Ja aber nicht dabei verrecken
Das ist ja das Problem
Der könnte Shatter haben
Oder hast du den Shatter gesehen in letzter Zeit?
Nee keinen
Der wird einen haben
Der guckt schon so
Dich heilt halt keiner
Der ist solo Shattered
High Quality Matches Leute
Absolut High Quality
Ich weiß nicht warum
Der unbedingt das Lucio spielen musste
Ich versuche zumindest vorzukommen
Ne
Das wars
Alles klar
Perfektes Match zum Start
Zieh raus direkt
Jaja kannst du rausziehen
Ich dachte du hättest das Game
Rage deinstalliert, hatte ich auch
Vielleicht mache ich das mal wieder
Ich mache dann auch gleich mit
Also wenn das jetzt noch zweimal geht
Dann habe ich keinen Bock mehr
Ey ich verlor meine Standplates waren ziemlich
Ver-aimed
Aber der Rest war ja wieder absolut
Grausam
Das ist echt eine Katastrophe
Dass du deine Placement so knapp vor Seasonende
Noch machen kannst
Vor allem erst spielt der Mercy und wir hatten eigentlich
Eine ganz gute Comp
Und ein Switch dazwischen drin Lucio
Und ich weiß nicht warum
Ich verstehs nicht
Aber wir haben es schon
Abgerade 3 Legendaries
Aus 4 Lootboxen
Reingelackt würde ich sagen
Naja mal gucken was jetzt passiert
Ja
Mal gucken
Mal suchen
Leute
Ich frage an chat
Was sagt ihr?
Huge Mercy Plays ja oder nein?
Massive
Massive Mercy Plays ja oder nein?
Weil für die Comp
Müsste ichs machen, auch wenn ich keinen Bock hab
Keine Mercy
Ja was du
Ne
Gut
Ich mein
Es ist im Prinzip egal
Was ich picke
Es ist trotzdem scheiße
So
Easy
Ich spring jetzt rein
Du könntest mich damage boosten
Ja das stimmt Leute
Ich muss mal
Die erste Runde Mercy spielen
Dass ich unsere Widow damage boosten kann
Ich mach Damage Boost Mercy
Das ist noch spannender als Heal Mercy
Ich steh jetzt einfach noch bei Eaxe
Damage Boost die
Hanzo
Du kannst
Skatter kannst du gleich machen
Skatter
Ich bin nicht da
So
Du machst das schon
Nein
Der beste
Können wir pushen Leute
Pushen
Wir haben einen Pick
Ich mach jetzt Battle Mercy
Das ist spannender zu sehen
Pushen
Damage Boost
Damage Boost incoming
Easy, easy damage boost
Die haben Westen Turret
Wow
Spat
Gedingst hier
Ich weiß nicht genau was das war
So
Das läuft schon wieder gut
Wer kann
Dieses Matchmaking
Nicht lieben
Ich glaube unsere Tracer macht das gerade alleine
Die Tracer hat die mehr oder weniger alleine gebashed
Skatter
Ich mein wer kann dieses Matchmaking nicht lieben
Und generell Overwatch rank
Das ist eigentlich nicht möglich
Das muss man lieben
Skatter, komm Skatter sie weg
Skatter
Nice
Hinter dir ist ein Sen
Ich hab schiss
Pass auf der ist dumm
Der hat nix getroffen
Lul der Sen
bei mir ruckelts grad schon wieder übel
moment leute leute ich muss da rüber
moment sind da wieder alle verreckt kann das sein?
das ist geil
oh man schrankt perfekt
skater
kam irgendwann mal ein overwatch patch raus in der letzten wache
in den letzten 10 tagen
es ruckelt wie scheiße
ich weiß nicht
ich hab battle net aufgemacht eben gerade und das ging
also ohne updates und so
skater
ich komm mal zu dir geflogen
skater sie weg
ich seh dich da oben net für damage boosts
nein
diese matches beste beste
denk an den win-loss-counter, den aktualisier ich net
das hat keinen sinn grade
so jetzt machen wir ein special pick
pass auf die werden als voll überrascht die gegner
die wissen gar nicht was ihnen geschieht
ne zeit ist ja schon vorbei
es läuft grade bei mir mit gefühlt 10 fps so
das ist kacke
hat sich deine grafik irgendwie resettet oder sowas
grafik settings
das hatte ich mal
ich ja nicht nein
das hatte ich mal da stand auf einmal wieder auf 144
guck mal wie dein render scale ist
100% alles so wie normal
jetzt sind die ruckel wieder weg so
neue runde zack weg
merkwürdig
aber im prinzip ist ja nicht schlimm ich meine 10 fps sind nur zwei weniger als das auge sieht
also macht das eigentlich überhaupt nix
was ist das hier eigentlich wieder grade
das ist absolut kindergarten und kein rank
da
so
was ist das
ruckel ist jetzt wieder bei dir
start mal rechner neu danach
hab ich schon vorhin
dann weiß ich auch nicht
ja leute das ist der witz das ist der witz das ist master das habt ihr richtig gut erkannt im chat
das ist master
hier was ihr gerade seht
also das letzte match auch schon darf man nicht vergessen
das ist master
das ist quasi die zweithöchste skillstufe die dieses spiel hat ja
wer kann overwatch rank nicht lieben dafür
am ende der season bemüht sich keiner mehr eigentlich würde man eigentlich vermuten am ende der season machen alle den mega tryhard mode
weil sie noch ein gutes placement haben wollen aber nicht in overwatch
achtung achtung huge ana place was
ist der einfach durchgegangen
weißt du
ist der sleep da durch den junkie durchgeflogen gerade
matchmaking ist auf gold 10 mal professioneller
mag sein
ich glaube das ist einfach random
overwatch ist halt einfach random ins pur
das hat auch keinen sinn hier gerade
huge nade huge nade
oh du lebst noch
scatter hast gescattert schön
achtung achtung achtung achtung achtung
oh ne
ich wollte die tracer noch baschen
das war das hat ich hatte so viel spaß ich hab's richtig enjoyed jetzt quasi
matches
willst du nochmal neu starten
keine ahnung ob das es bringt ich hab ja vorhin schon
da hatte ich das auch
deswegen interessiert es mich ob da ein patch gekommen ist oder nicht
also ich kann mich jetzt nicht dran erinnern dass irgendwo ein patch da war
dachte du hast rage uninstalled
ich wollte dem game noch mal eine chance geben am letzten
besten zwei matches bisher gehabt
wobei ich sagen muss das letzte match mit der bestchen top combo das war
eigentlich schon die krönung ja
und wisst ihr was das allerbeste ist
man darf den nicht reporten
weil jeff sagt das ist griefing wenn man die reportet dafür
ich hab ne meldung bekommen
dass das irgendjemand eine disciplinarmaßnahme bekommen hat
das kannst du nicht vorstellen
du hast 100.000 reports eine meldung zurück
na immerhin ja
kann ich suchen oder willst du noch irgendwas ausprobieren
ja kann suchen
huge other place
ja
battlefield 4
ja trau mich
ich muss ja sagen mittlerweile ist battlefield 4 in einem echt gut spielbaren
zustand
ich persönlich finde zwar battlefield 3 immer noch besser
aber battlefield 4 kann man mittlerweile richtig gut spielen
kein vergleich zu battlefield 1 was mir ja gar nicht gefällt habe ich aber schon oft genug gesagt
ja hast du mal mit der battlefield 1 gespielt
in letzter zeit du fandest das ja ganz gut
ich fand das eigentlich nie gut
also am anfang hat sich das so angehört als findest du das super
ja grafikverblendung
du hast quasi die schwächen nicht gesehen
genau
ist halt immer so wenn du ein neues spiel startest und sowas dann siehst du die schwächen erst mal gar nicht
gegen serino bruder nein nein nein nein
ah nur serino du bist gm tank ne ich hab mal irgendwann einen stream gesehen letzte woche oder was vorletzte woche kommt mir bekannt vor der name
beide weil wenn dir rush so gut gefällt spiel mal dirty bomb nein
wir hätten beide auf rino
ich wollte mich ja ursprünglich topkeks nennen
weiß auch nicht warum ich mich topkeks genannt habe
was klappt das
ich mein wir haben zwar keine mercy dabei aber
das sieht zumindest aus als könnte es was werden
das huge winston plays
jetzt kommt der huge junkrat spam und wir verrecken alle
tommy das ist eine geile idee
klats fps ja das trifft sie ja auch ziemlich gut bei mir mittlerweile
wir lasern jetzt erst mal die trap weg falls da eine liegt
legt aber gar keine da
wird das etwa eine no junkrat spam runde
achte achte achte gut wo ist unsere mercy
jetzt gehts voll rein hier
schreckt
weil wir den shield behalten sollen
nächste season spiele ich ein bisschen mehr winston dann gehts ab damit
kann man winston eigentlich hier drüber hüpfen
nein geht nicht
hätte sein können
da kommt von hinten ein reinhart
wer ist hier reingeschossen haben soll
hallo hallo
aber der 360 jump der geht
ich gehe schon mal vor aufs dach
was da abgeht
tresor
wohin hat die recalled
ja meine winston jumps
leck an der
oh nein nein das ist ein roadhog
hier
was was die kacke maßia
fack
huge mercy plays
ob das unser naryo ist da manchmal auch im chat ist
was ist deine mainrolle support
und ich hab seit diesen drei nicht mehr richtig gespielt
deswegen habe ich mir auch den neuen account gemacht
achte achte ich jetzt jetzt gehts voll klar oben rechts rein
fack ich dachte ich komm rechtzeitig raus
seine mainrolle ist gecarried von eaxe also kann man das auch sagen
vor allem in season 3
hat die night
meine winston jumps sind legendär wie man hier sieht
oder auch
irgendwie geht da grad nicht viel
doch da geht schon ein bisschen was aber
du machst das
kommt man hier durch
da kommt eine kleine tracer von hinten
ein bisschen geht was aber nicht genug
so sind wir alle da
das ist
das ist lull 3d
dachte du hast deinstalliert
ja ich hab auch deinstalliert nach den letzten drei games
vom stream vorher die ersten zwei games heute war er schon wieder
grausam
das ist ja schlimmer
ich hab nicht so ich gehe mal auf die war ich hab nicht das gefühl dass ich
irgendwie
das passt doch gerade so
ich krieg voll auf die fresse er
ich überlebt nicht mal lange noch zu wieder zurück hüpfen
hast du schon mal auf dem ptr diese neuen in der luft steuerdinger ausprobiert
dass man angeblich besser steuern kann in der luft
du meinst das noch schlechter an emulation da sind
ich verpiss mich
die tracer
oh huge hand so old
massive
ok sind wir da
ich geh mal rein
alter der stirbt nicht was ist das
bitte helf
the fuck
der mcree hätte eben einfach sterben können
links ist mcree drin
die leute sind wieder schon zu ängstlich die heilen fehlt
auf gehts
die
rekt
wir sollten mal pushen ich hoffe da gleich wieder rein sobald wir am start sind dann gehts mit old werden sie spawnen gehämmert
als einen
war sie nein hey der winston ist gerade in der wand gehangen die gegner
das hat mich voll desorientiert so ich guckte so an was macht er da drin das war
richtig sie nahe gerade
die haben die irgendwas ich war zu sehr mit rum hüpfen und grillen beschäftigt
haben die irgendwas flänkermäßiges gespielt die an der trace hatten sie
ne aber die war perma tot aber kein aber kein genji oder sowas
kann ich wieder ein bisschen üben mit zenyatta die bälle zu treffen
tommy wir haben hartz hineint am letzten punkt aber das ist so gut wie durch
das schwere stück haben wir eigentlich gepackt ich frage mich eben auf auf die
auf diesen ganzen mehr sei es auf 2 cp maps der zweite moment ja passt der
zweite punkt oder auch ja hier eichenwald der letzte punkten so ich frage
mich was blitzer da geritten hat das frage ich mich schon seit der beta im
endeffekt was blitzer da geritten hat die spawns immer direkt hinter den letzten
punkt zu machen ich mein es hätte ja auch kein es hätte sich ja keine ein
bein abgebrochen wenn man die spawns ein bisschen weiter hintergemacht hätte und
quasi wenn man noch nicht in der letzten phase ist dann eben ein stückchen weiter
vorne spawned jetzt doch echt keiner bei etwas abgebrochen oder nicht zenyatta
mein eigentlich lucio mehr im herz lucio mein leider kann man lucio nicht
ordentlich spielen zur zeit zumindest nicht hier auf auf payloads das einzige
wo ich ihn aktuell noch halbwegs sinnvoll sehe ist so was wie entweder
eventuell entweder willst du übelst hart reinpushen so auf die auf dem bahn die
erster punkt oder halt king of the hill dann dann doch oh oh no we don't we don't
nicht sterben leute nicht sterben fack fack fack ich bin fast dauernd muss
ich muss kurz hier alter die fahrer fu wie sie dann da reinkommen
gar mitgekriegt oh
ich merke schon muss ich selber wusste wusste wusste ich kann es noch
chance ich gehe mal hoch die mann mich fecken ob die maß
zu lau reinhard reinhard reinhard
unser reinhard braucht hilfe ja ich bin schon unten weil ich bin auch
runter oh jetzt wird es geht ab
ich habe eine tracer
auf wohl fack die mit der main schnup voll demlich gestanden
schub scheder schub schmerz ich weiß pommi ich weiß aber ich habe jetzt eine
woche nicht mehr gespielt in diesen nicht viel zen ich fühle mich nicht
sonderlich sicher gerade mit dem helden
im
Oh, mach sie doch tot!
Ihr müsst zu mir kommen, ihr müsst zu mir kommen!
Was? Der wollte dich abkörren und hat mich erwischt.
Leie.
Der hätte mich pushen müssen.
Ich hatte hinter mir einen McCree, ich wusste zu eins und sonst war ich instant verreckt.
Leute, wo wollt...
Was fehlt hat die frontline, weil wir jetzt wieder keinen Tank haben?
Oh fuck, ich switch jetzt.
Komm, wir machen jetzt mal hier ein fettes Schild, gutes.
Hast du schon einmal gewonnen?
Äh, ne, ne, ich hab...
Die letzten zwei Matches waren so kacke, das ist das erste ganz gute Match.
Nice.
Niiiice!
Niiice!
Wirklich viel trifft hier wieder auch nicht.